une manifestation mardi des personnels
soignants et mobilisation cet après midi
des acteurs du monde de la nuit
un rassemblement devant le ministère de
la santé pour appeler à la réouverture
des discothèques à l'instar des bars et
des restaurants
malgré la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire les établissements de nuit
reste fermé au public
aucune réouverture n'est pour l'instant
prévue avant septembre
et on en parle avec eux en direct dans
ce gîte et patrick malvaes président du
sndll le syndicat national des
discothèques et lieux de loisirs
bonjour patrick malvaes merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct ce
matin sur rtl france aucune rue verture
de prévu avant septembre donc
quel avenir pour les établissements de
nuit la ville de cesson
sur le flanc depuis 8 heures les
exploitants ont eux mêmes en grande
difficulté puisqu'ils n'ont pas de quoi
nourrir leurs prêts villiers et ensuite
dès l'ouverture à septembre évoqué
peut-être intimiste parce que si on a
une seconde crise
cette ouverture droit peut-être lieu
peut bien après mois de septembre donc
l'eau historique on angoisse la
profession les patrons bénéficie-t-il
d'une aide de l'état les patrons des
établissements de nuit et qu'est ce que
vous attendez du gouvernement
concrètement va les battre on salarié
inapte à vous de grande solidarité point
barre vous ne savez pas grand chose il
s'appelait déjà quatre points cela dure
il s'avére cet oubli mois à l'arrivée ce
qu'on demande au gouvernement c'est
premièrement un fonds de secours
d'urgence au moins assumé les pistes et
établissements qui contient un coup et
deuxièmement un ensemble de mesures
d'accompagnement pays européens
gouvernementales telles que les premiers
baigneurs été mis en place
il faut un blocage des loyers avec un
bruce habilité à nous aider clause
d'expulsion si on paie pas son loyer
elle est chez nous demander d'être pas
toute une série de mesures que nous
avons listé evo troisième en remettre à
plat les conditions de la concurrence
parce qu actuellement il ya un très très
gros problème tout le monde peut faire
des sauts textes sauf les discothèques
et on voit les discothèques partout dans
des villes à part
donc si on veut bien et on peut
participer à l'effort national de
salubrité de santé on va mettre les
pionniers là dessus il faudrait
peut-être que on combat les dérives qui
ont lieu dans d'autres lieux un petit le
barde donc pas qu'on soit contre c'est
dur se réjouit qui fonctionne et il ya
des dérives qui sont insupportables
élaborer et mettre au pas et là on
ressentirait - dustin wahl éviter de la
décision de fermeture des discothèques
quand vous parlez de dérive qu'est ce
que c'est bah les dérives se sont
interdits on voit des locations sur rbs
19,3 des soirées qui sont organisés dans
des lieux privés on voit des rêves des
free party c'est encore juste ce soir
j'ai signalé au petit air de l'intérieur
partout partout partout on voit des
saunas qui sont ouverts et qui
fonctionne on voit un ensemble de lieux
où c'est encore pire ce papa du canal
saint martin elle passe sous le pont de
la villette j'ose pas en parler et puis
c'est partout et tout le monde le
constate dans les rues
c'est bien d'ailleurs ceci s'est passé
le 21 juin sont aussi mal donc il faut
faire très très attention
et ici on veut préserver la santé
publique il faut la préserver par tous
et pas prendre un bouc émissaire et
uniquement les discothèques
ça c'est intolérable surtout que les
exploitants leurs familles les
entreprises sont au bord du dépôt de
bilan son tombeur personnellement et on
va voir demain 7 à cucq salahi qu'on se
pose c'est d'équivalence qu'a eu lieu au
lycée aéronautique à fond la grosse
différence c'est que isole les
milliardaires et nous on n'a rien pour
l'instant
vous appelez à une réouverture de vos
établissements ou
on l'a vu sur ces images de la fête de
la musique le 21 juin une promiscuité
vous savez également que les lieux des
nuits sont également des lieux de
promiscuité ou la propagation du courant
d'un virus du coup peut être forte
on l'a vu récemment notamment avec un
malade atteint du corps un navire russe
en corée du sud qui avait fait la
tournée des bars le pays avait dû
refermer ces établissements si vous
ouvrez à nouveau quelles mesures peuvent
être prises pour éviter des
contaminations vous n'avez pas eu peur
d'être un vecteur de propagation
nous avons proposé au complet proposant
une prise de température personnes qui
rentrent dans vos et à l'histoire des
discothèques c'est pas une auberge
espagnole ouvert 80 on a une génération
et on peut parfaitement sélectionner des
gens qui rentrent dans l atelier choses
très important ensuite c'est une même
classe d'âge ce sont des mêmes bout
constitue etc
nous pouvons avoir des visages unique
nous pouvons même restreint de la danse
pouvoir l'empêcher totalement sans pour
autant comme licite et on peut très bien
un adulte ça se sent sans aucun problème
puisqu'on a le personnel en plus et est
dédié pour la surveillance puisqu'il
serait de cartes professionnelles qui on
est les seuls à pouvoir encadrer ces
petits en fait quand tu vois ce qui se
passe ailleurs
c'est pas du tout cas donc ça on peut
parfaitement le crès l'islande est l'un
des premiers premier pays d'europe à
avoir rouvert ses discothèques tu
c'était à la mi mai comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer et quelles sont les
mesures qui ont été prises là bas même
si peut-être que la circulation du
courant n'avait russe et est moindre
dans ce pays on s'est beaucoup inspiré
demandé comme le lecteur puisque le
canada a perdu aussi la réouverture
discothèque sous certaines conditions
la première condition c'est la piste de
danse thermique on est prêt la deuxième
condition c'est la prise de température
en ip la troisième condition sont toutes
les mesures par ailleurs
d'accompagnement ont nivelé et la
quatrième mesure est important ce serait
une modulation par eauze olympique
seulement à condition que toute la
chaîne fonctionnement des loisirs
festifs nocturnes soient également
réguler notre site c'est de taper 1
alors les menus à deux reprises en dix
ans disons qu'une réduction des horaires
mais ça c'est dit aussi au pays ça vaut
être le pays du soleil de minuit
là en l'occurrence ils ont fait arrêter
de cet épicentre de toutes sortes du
matin tous les établissements partout et
les bars parce qu'on veut fermeture
risque chez nous débarquons jusqu'à deux
heures c'est un sénateur a tenu de santé
on est tout à fait le gros problème
c'est la crédibilité quand on voit tous
les débordements de conjuguer les
discothèques sont tout à fait prêts à
elles sont pionnières dans cette lutte
là vous imaginez gagné tous ces
débordements une possible ou jean va
arriver au mois de septembre vous
pourrez pas ouverts parce que ya une
deuxième bague autour d'un virus sa
deuxième bague ou un virus aurait été
provoqué par tous les autres peuvent pas
résister puisqu'elle ne fonctionne pas
par définition
donc on va être des premiers sanctionnés
pour quelque chose qu'on n'aura pas plus
et ça ça ne fait que beaucoup ont le
dessus pour la santé à l'heure actuelle
mais conduit pour la santé dans trois ou
quatre mois parce qu on y aille intérêts
personnels et la collectivité lionel
terray sanitaire évident merci merci
patrick malvaes d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du syndicat national des
discothèques et des lieux de loisirs